on this saturday night
let the campaigning begin in nova scotia
another provincial election in the
pandemic can my kids go to school
are we going to be able to have steady
incomes the issues facing the premier
who was just sworn in
five months ago volatile tinderboxes
the race to keep up with wildfires
erupting across canada
and the u.s descent under a dictatorship
the cuban crisis fueling an uprising
plus
save the manatees they're very key
species
what's killing these gentle giants of
the sea
global national with robin gill
good evening and thank you for joining
us after weeks of speculation
the nova scotia government has called a
summer election
at the request to premier ian rankin the
lieutenant governor dissolved the
legislature
voters will head to the polls august
17th rankin is hoping to secure a third
consecutive term for his liberal party
this province is at a pivotal moment and
we need to
continue to make the right decisions for
workers for seniors
for families and for all nova scotians
this election will be about how we best
position the province for a strong
economic recovery rankin took office
before nova scotia entered its third
wave of the pandemic
there have been no new cases for four
days in a row and the province entered
phase four
of its reopening plan this week as ross
lord reports with no fixed election
dates in nova scotia
it's no coincidence the election is
being called now
the third wave of covet 19 is a thing of
the past in nova scotia
but the pandemic is still front and
center in the minds of the voting public
people are feeling a lot better about
what they need and what they want
and we look for good leadership can my
kids go to school
are we going to be able to have steady
incomes are businesses and shops going
to open back up
political analysts say liberal premier
ian rankin who's been on the job for
only five months
has good reason to be confident that
he'll continue a pandemic pattern
incumbents winning with an increased
number of seats
the feds have been showering the
province with cash the province has been
showering the people with spending
promises
the big health care unions have just
signed off in a sweet new agreement
the weather is warm the mood is high the
bills haven't come in yet so
all the ducks are now in a row a great
time for a sitting premier to go to the
polls
except there's been a recent setback for
rankin an impaired driving conviction
that just came to light
from when he was a young man i was fined
and my license was suspended for one
year
two years later i was charged with the
same offense but was eventually found to
be innocent
not exactly a breathalyzer test showed
rankin was impaired but
he won an appeal on a technicality and
was eventually let off the hook
political damage could be overshadowed
by a wide open money hose
funding things like the 10 a day child
care rank and promised along with the
federal government
at a cost of 600 million dollars
affordable child care will benefit
thousands of working families no doubt
particularly women and children in our
province the timing of the election
would see the campaign completed before
the start of the mass
casualty commission's public hearings
into the port-a-pick massacre
which left 22 people dead and sparked
outrage that authorities did not prevent
it
his opponents tim houston of the pcs and
the ndp's gary burrell
have more experience as leaders but
neither man has captured the public's
attention
something that could be a challenge for
all three in a summertime election
campaign
ross lord global news halifax
calls are growing for the bc government
to declare a state of emergency over the
province's devastating wildfires
thousands of people are in evacuation
order or alert
the fires are concentrated in
southeastern b.c and air quality alerts
are in place for about half the province
it's not just b.c burning up sweltering
heat has triggered an uptick of fires in
parts of the prairies
and ontario but as catherine ercart
reports more help
is on the way there it is
wildfires burning across b.c now total
more than
300 it's an unprecedented situation
with residents of 2000 plus homes
on evacuation order to date
we've had roughly 240 000 hectares
burned
we're generally at 65 or so thousand
hectares
burned there have been continued calls
for the provincial government to declare
a state of emergency
the premier says it's not warranted and
he'll wait
until it's requested by emergency
management officials
i'm absolutely prepared to call a state
of emergency when it is required by
those professionals
that are putting their lives on the line
100 mile house
and ashcroft are among the communities
on evacuation alert
long-term care residents have been moved
in case the fires advance
at the cunningham cattle ranch they're
surrounded by flames
right in the middle of it it's all
around us
except for the little bit on the east
side
the village of litton which was
decimated by wildfire june
30th is planning a rebuild it will be
challenging
everything was destroyed including the
town's office
and their two servers the residents
whose houses
are no more we are they'll be in
hotels until such time as we get our
temporary housing
in place also battling record-setting
wildfires
saskatchewan an alert was issued
discouraging
all non-essential travel in the
province's north
where wildfires threaten a number of
communities
hopefully our firefighters are safe so
they're doing one
or one heck of a job give my hat to them
bc's wildfire smoke has also been
blowing into alberta
resulting in air quality advisories
and the fire season is far from over
more help for bc's firefighters is
expected in the days ahead
with personnel coming from across the
country
more than 100 firefighters from mexico
are expected to arrive in a week
catherine ercart global news vancouver
dozens of wildfires are also scorching
parts of the u.s tonight this wall of
flames on the border between california
and nevada
exploded overnight triggering
evacuations
jennifer johnson looks at what's fanning
the flames south of the border
two million americans in several western
states are under red flag warnings
alerts that wildfires are raging out of
control oregon's bootleg fire is the
season's first official
mega fire of 2021 consuming over 97
thousand hectares
80 year old couple out there that have
worked their whole lives for a home and
you know we go and save it the bootleg
fire is now seven times the size of san
francisco
in washington only three of 10 of that
state's largest wildfires are contained
as fire officials order more evacuations
it was a little emotional having to wake
you know a seven and eight year old up
and telling them you gotta leave the
house
in california the beckworth fire is the
state's largest
taking homes from 33 families in the
small town of doyle
right now there's a lot of emotion a lot
of anger
everybody believes that the fire should
never have made it this far further
west the dixie fire is coming
dangerously close to paradise
a town destroyed three years ago by the
camp fire
it's just an icky feeling because you
never know
and you don't know if it's gonna you
never know more than 60 percent of the
u.s west
is suffering from extreme drought the
highest rating since monitoring began 20
years ago
scientists say human-caused climate
change is producing more heat but no
rain
the perfect combination to fuel fires
lake mead which provides water to four
states
is at its lowest level since the 1930s
climate change has a very strong
fingerprint on exactly what we're seeing
right now at lake mead
it has never been this low it really
truly is unprecedented
officials closed the lake this weekend
to boaters citing dangerous
low water levels everything is drying up
it's like a stocked fireplace
tinder packed ready to go up this fire
season is about six weeks ahead of
schedule
and already more land has burned than in
2020
worrying those on the front lines the
vegetation around here is very
very dry very dangerous one little any
little spark can you know ignite another
flame and another another fire and it's
off to the races again
firefighters are weary and stretched
thin with the worst of the fire season
yet to come
jennifer johnson global news washington
record flood waters are receding in
parts of europe where at least 170
people were killed
in hard hit germany levels are now low
enough for divers to search for bodies
in stranded vehicles
the heaviest rainfall in a century burst
river banks and swept through
communities all over western europe
pumps are working around the clock to
remove excess water
and sandbags are still going up over
fear's dams could collapse
in the u.k health officials are accusing
prime minister boris johnson of letting
covet rip
on monday britain will end lockdown
restrictions despite daily new cases
reaching a six-month high
and the newly appointed health secretary
is among those who have tested positive
i'm now self-isolating at home with my
family until i get the results
sajid javid says he's thankful to be
fully vaccinated and only has mild
symptoms
but 32 percent of british adults and
children have not had both doses
the uk reported more than 54 000 new
cases today
with the delta variant accounting for 90
percent
of new infections less than a week
before the olympics begin an
overseas visitor has tested positive for
covet at the athletes village in tokyo
the person who was involved in
organizing the games is now in
quarantine
the case further fuels concerns the
virus could spread
through olympic facilities back here in
canada more people are getting immunized
against covet 19.
about 80 percent of everyone eligible
has received one dose
more than half of canadians age 12 and
older are fully vaccinated
but one group gen zed is hesitant to get
the shot
and that could be a big barrier to mass
immunity as jamie morocco explains
there's a mission to get these young
people motivated to roll up their
sleeves
[Music]
21-year-old tori parento knows the best
way to reach her generation is
through social media so it was a
no-brainer for her to use the power of
her platforms to spread awareness about
the copin 19 vaccine
teaming up with a gaming company and a
campaign called lg i got the shot
and we got close to five and a half
million people to pay attention to the
campaign
public health experts say vaccinating
young adults is essential to keeping
infection numbers low
in the u.s just 42 percent of 18 to 24
year olds have been fully vaccinated
compared to 60 percent of all adults in
canada in part to delayed vaccine
rollouts the numbers are currently even
lower
with just under 30 percent of ages 18 to
29 double dosed
there's always this daring aspect this
risk taking aspect
those feelings of invincibility and
immortality are only part of the problem
say experts adding misinformation fear
and complacency can all be reasons that
gen z don't get the jab
and the solutions not one size fits all
you're not going to solve it because
people are going to react in
different ways but there is i still
think a commonality of sense
of common sense into which we can tap
and if that doesn't work star power can
be influential too
i'm in awe of the work president biden
and dr fauci have done
and was happy to help lend my support to
this important initiative
that's 18 year old pop star olivia
rodrigo promoting vaccination at the
white house this week
piranha supports that kind of psa but
says mostly her generation is just
looking for clear facts
based off of how everyone sees it it
kind of seems like
a lot of them are overwhelmed with the
amount of information
hoping to use her reach to spread
information responsibly
and influence others to do their part to
end the pandemic
jamie morocco global news toronto a
search for unmarked graves got underway
today at the former delmos residential
school in saskatchewan
crews are using ground penetrating radar
to scour the former school grounds
the school was operated by the roman
catholic church from 1901
to 1948 when it burned down
coming up the call for political change
in communist cuba
in the communist country of cuba
speaking out can have dire consequences
so scenes like this are rare thousands
of cubans have taken to the streets to
show
they're not afraid and they're fed up
the pandemic
the poor economy a crisis over food and
medicine
and a lack of freedom have tempers
flaring reggie chikini tonight on the
descent born from desperation
and the hopes the world will take notice
the echoes of the largest revolt in
decades still resonate in the streets of
cuba
frustrated hungry and terrified
residents hurled their anger towards a
government
they see as having failed the country
this protester says the crowd's chanted
we want medicine
we want food
the island's coffers are empty there's a
critical food shortage the health care
system is in shambles
vaccine supply is limited
and after initially blaming america's
embargo for the crisis
cuba's president accepted some
responsibility a rare moment of
contrition
the government since it is somewhat
allergic
to doing real change maybe that's
what's happening that they're seeing
their survival at stake here
the protests driven by social media led
to an internet shutdown to prevent the
world from seeing the chaos
the uprising has fostered fears of a new
wave of defections by
boat but freedom a mere 120 kilometers
away
feels impossibly out of reach for most
if you take
to the sea you will not come
to the united states the biden
administration is facing mounting
pressure from the cuban exile community
to do something
i don't have anything to predict for you
in terms of any policy shift
the more aggressive in tone that the u.s
responds to this the greater the degree
to which
the government in cuba says see this is
an excuse for the u.s
to act aggressively ottawa has also been
criticized for taking a passive approach
to the crisis
but changed its tune on thursday we
stand as we always will
with the people of cuba who want and
deserve
democracy freedom and respect
the protest did lead to minor
concessions a temporary lift on
restrictions
limiting how much food or medicine
travelers can bring in
a band-aid solution to an economic
meltdown
part of what we're seeing is this call
for the government to be
much more accountable and to essentially
say you know deal with this or leave
you know and let somebody else do it
even if fractures formed from this
historic pushback the cuban government
is giving no indication it intends to
further bend
reggie kinney global news washington
still ahead the species at risk why are
manatees dying at an alarming rate
don't blink or you'll miss it it might
look like a bug on your screen but that
is the international space station seen
transiting
past the moon the site was captured from
spain's canary islands in slow motion
according to nasa the space station
travels at a speed of nearly 25 000
kilometers per hour
as it orbits earth approximately 16
times a day
the race is on tonight to stop an
ecological disaster in the waters of
florida
and save the state's marine mammal
manatees are known to be quite resilient
learning to adapt to the environment
around them
but this year an unprecedented number
has perished
jackson proska explains why these sea
creatures are starving to death
and who's to blame there's a reason
they're called sea cows
manatees are the gentle giants of the
ocean
in normal times they lumber along
searching for warm water
and grazing on sea grass but this year
has proven especially deadly and
difficult for the species
manatees are dying off at an alarming
rate
the man is actually a really good
indicator of what's happening in the
environment they're very key species
so seeing so many manatees die is
actually an indicator that there is
definitely something wrong
something very wrong with the ecosystem
at least 840 manatees have died
so far this year in florida far
surpassing the total number of deaths
for all of 2020
more often than not they're starving the
seagrass they eat is being choked out by
algae blooms
fertilizers and runoff end up in the
water feeding the blooms
which block the sunlight needed to grow
the manatees food supply
it's affecting all the fish the crabs
everything that's
dependent on the water out here and sea
grass florida's
saved the manatee club recently rescued
and rehabilitated an emaciated manatee
named mandy
along with her calf mandy weighed just
400 kilograms
she should have weighed over 1 000 that
just shows you
how amazing that she really was when she
was rescued and
that's the case with a lot of manatees
out there a devastating outbreak of red
tide in florida has only added to the
manatees woes
they're being killed off along with
thousands of fish and other sea mammals
the situation is now so dire
environmentalists are pushing for
manatees to be added back to the
endangered species list
it's a problem that we cannot fix
overnight but first and foremost we do
need to clean up the water quality we do
need to replant sea grasses
time is not on the manatees side they
reproduce slowly
and at current rates up to one third of
florida's manatee population could die
this year it's a man-made disaster
that threatens this beloved ocean mammal
jackson prosko global news washington
up next the canadian entrepreneur who is
giving back to indigenous communities
a canadian entrepreneur is making a name
for herself in the makeup industry
jennifer harper started cheekbone beauty
with only five hundred dollars
now she's taking orders from the other
side of the world but her company is
about more than just cosmetics as kayla
mclean explains
it's about empowering indigenous people
to believe in themselves
so you just scoop it and scrape it in
owning her own lab in cosmetic line
cheekbone beauty is the stuff jennifer
harper's dreams are made of
literally i had a dream about lip gloss
and super happy dative little girls back
in 2015
and that night i literally grabbed my
laptop and started writing out the
business plan
from no industry experience to ceo of a
canadian made beauty brand receiving
orders as far as australia
some days i sit there and i'm like what
who's this what's happening here
it feels surreal partly because of how
much she's overcome
alcoholism identity issues and the pain
of losing her brother to suicide
learning her grandmother was a
residential school survivor made
everything click if there is a trauma
that does tend to go on for generations
unless someone chooses
to correct it or heal it understanding
the lasting effects of colonial abuse on
indigenous people propelled the
anishinabe entrepreneur to break the
cycle
empowered by her brother's last words to
her he said our youth need hope and they
need help
harper evolved cheekbone beauty into a
makeup brand where indigenous people can
feel supported
celebrated and seen original collection
was called the warrior women every one
of these shades
was named after a really inspiring
strong indigenous woman
and for every makeup product sold a
portion of the proceeds go back to
organizations supporting indigenous
communities
for us as a business it's about
supporting indigenous youth and sort of
any idea of any education endeavor
that they choose to go on the indie
brand is not only giving back to people
but the planet too so when the
lipstick's all done
you literally would just take the cap
and this can go in your compost and it
is biodegradable
created with sustainable ingredients and
packaging her products are named after
the words for land in several first
nations languages
reflecting the people's deep connection
to nature and duty to future generations
she's paving the way for us indigenous
regalia maker deanne hubfield who's
mentored by harper sees cheekbone
beauty's work as not only healing
but motivating no other indigenous
women are are doing a business like
first so it's
at this time it's really great to see
that we know that we're not the solution
to all of these big huge problems that
happen around us
but if we can be like a little glimmer
of light in in sort of a dark space then
we feel really good about the work we're
doing
kayla mclean global news and that is
global national for this saturday night
i'm robin gill
tonight your canada is lake huron in the
town of blind river ontario we would
love to see your corner of the country
so please
keep sending your photos to viewers at
globalnational.com
thank you for watching and i'll see you
back here tomorrow have a great night
[Music]